when you do something like this long
enough and you do the what we get to do
which is like play and make believe for
a living
it's uh
it's hard to come by humans like real
people
that love other humans yeah forgive me
if I cry wow are you kidding uh yeah
you're speaking oh my God
[Applause]
it's just really really special like you
need to understand my wife read my wife
read your most recent book really Wild
flower so she read the book and she
loved it loved it true that you guys met
when you were a kid you were 9 and 13. I
mean that is
straight up it's just incredible
towering oh guys y'all Buckle in
so we're 9 and 13 we're at a dance
studio in Birmingham Alabama that's
where we met and we were kids and we
grew up dancing together and singing and
and doing the thing and then I was
working on Hamilton almost this 2016. so
she came to see the show we got dinner
and then we got dinner again and then we
got lunch and then we decided that we
only wanted to get dinners and lunch
with each other and that was
what was that I know you have a 10 month
I have a 10 month old this is his first
talk show he's here I don't know where
he is
[Applause]
oh my gosh that's my that's my best
friend right there man he's uh Riley
Riley William Fisher that to me is what
sets my joy and my happiness my like
what's innate and lives inside of me
apart from everything else because it's
easy for me to block out the noise when
I'm with my family and with
my kid with my wife but I think it's
important to mention especially for the
sake of this conversation you know we
were
four months pregnant five months
pregnant always wanted to be a dad knew
that I was about to achieve that that
goal and and take on the biggest and
best project of my life with my my
partner my best friend and
um
I was diagnosed with an eating disorder
that I did not know that I had
um I just knew that I had reflux and
like all of these things that were
making it difficult for me to eat and
didn't realize that there were all of
these traumas from my childhood that I
needed to work through in therapy is
really it's insane so there in my last
couple of months of my contract were
very very difficult physical times for
me this is something that no like I lost
30 pounds I've been active I actually
never talked about this uh out loud on a
platform like this at all and man I'm so
glad that I made it through that desert
because here we are now talking to you I
am so much stronger
thank God for that thank God for them
how do you think you became you
um my parents without question I'm
adopted gotta really gotta got a pretty
cool story
um I'll not show up for you we'll we'll
have some wine we'll talk I would love
nothing we will we will chat later
um my parents are incredible they've
they've uh they they have had things
happen to them that they've had to
navigate that I wouldn't wish on my
worst enemy yet have shown me nothing
but patience and kindness and love and
gave me the opportunity to as a kid grow
up with a voice and debate when I felt
like that was something that I needed to
do if I had a point that I wanted to
make I was never silenced I was just
taught to respectfully allow my voice to
be heard but what that did was it just
it gave me the practice of listening
and I heard some phrase at some point in
time that a fool speaks and a wise man
listens and you know I I love you know
like
um tomorrow night I'm gonna I love
taking the kids to Broadway we're gonna
come see your show I'm so excited are
you kidding
my God and it is a privilege and it is
so lucky it's getting like rave reviews
it is the hit that everybody hoped it
might be and that nobody wants to make
anything that you know isn't a success
but this one really is so for me and
anyone who is privileged enough to go
see Sweeney Todd what should we be
looking out for because this is the show
everybody's talking about and I cannot
wait it's a dark comedy it is a dark
comedy yes there's blood there's a crazy
Barber Shop with a crazy barber in there
down the street on Fleet Street and you
want to avoid him at all costs because
he is you know he's uh he's taken a
slice out of life for everybody you
understand
[Applause]
[Laughter]
um
so it's it's so special Natasha Katz
who's our lighting designer um the Big
Challenge here I think was not how well
she could light the show but how well
she could remove light from the space
she does this so beautifully it's a
thrilling thrilling piece if you don't
think that you can go to a theater and
sit down and be antsy and stressed and
thrilled think again come see Sweeney
Todd Josh Groban one of the best
vocalists who I'm also so obsessed with
as a goddess so if you're not going to
Broadway to see Sweeney Todd you have
five million followers on tick tock
[Applause]
oh
it's weird I think that there are five
million people that have tapped a little
red button on their phone 5 million
it's kind of wild will you do a tick
tock challenge with that I'll do it
[Music]